just when you think america has reached
the maximum level of queerness not just
a little light in the loafers but full
on queerer than a three dollar bill just
when you think things cannot get any
queerer
the speaker of the house of
representatives appears on a drag queen
tv show to declare that transvestitism
is what america is all about
please give a warm drag race welcome to
the speaker of the house
nancy pelosi
welcome back
my honor to be here
to say to all of you how proud we all
are of you
thank you for the joy and beauty you
bring to the world ah your freedom of
expression of yourselves in drag is what
america is all about i say that all the
time to my friends in drag
[Laughter]
that's what america is all about quote
our constitution was built for moral and
religious people
and more than that
it's built for dudes to strap on
stilettos and strut around like cartoon
caricatures of a prostitute it is wholly
inadequate to the government of any
other so said john adams did he i don't
i don't think so it is
increasingly however the view held by
our elite institutions which are
uniformly promoting transvestitism and
transgenderism and transsexualism
including among children and the voices
calling for this child abuse and this
perversion and this madness
are not just on the radical left the
situation has gotten so bad in this
country
even the largest conservative cable news
channel has joined the chorus not just
waving the rainbow flag but even
encouraging parents to trans their kids
i had to blink on friday i had to clear
my eyes and shake my head and blink
because i know it's june and in june
everything goes super gay and it doesn't
just go gay gay is now bourgeois gay is
now old-fashioned and traditional now it
goes trans and it doesn't just go trans
for the adults it goes trans for the
kids so i know that i expect that from
all the left-wing news outlets which is
to say almost all the news outlets i
expect this from all the left-wing
corporations which is to say almost all
the corporations i expect this certainly
from all the left-wing tv channels which
is to say most of the tv channels
but i saw
a segment
being run
not just on the topic of transgenderism
not just on the topic of transgendering
the kids but act actively promoting
transiting the kids and i saw this
segment not on msnbc
and not on cnn
i saw it on fox news
fourteen-year-old ryland whittington is
a typical southern california teenager
and the whittingtons along with mom
hillary dad jeff and sister brinley are
a typical family the only difference
though in ryland's eyes is what this
family can mean to the tens of thousands
of kids under 18
who identify as transgender we put our
story out there so people could
see that like there's another family out
there that
is
going through what we're going through
or there's another family who's proud of
who they are before ryland could even
speak he managed to tell his parents
that he is a boy i could just see it it
wasn't him trying to be
a brat it was like painful it was truly
painful for him to have to wear feminine
clothing and and for us constantly
telling him that you're a girl and
unlike some trans kids when rylan came
out at age five a few years later he had
the full support of his parents i'm just
here to make the ride smoother for
others what extraordinary courage
displayed by ryland his sister brinley
father jeff and mom hillary i want to
thank the whittington family for
speaking to us it's not easy
particularly at a time when when
transgender issues have been politicized
people are afraid of what they do not
understand this family hopes their story
will lead to more understanding more
acceptance and ultimately more love
and ultimately
more love
that's the last word there this is not
just covering
this this is not just
well look at this weird story it would
be abusive enough to run a big segment
go out film this family and this poor
little girl where they're obviously
screwing up this poor girl on all sorts
of hormones and that's why her voice is
so much deeper
that that would be bad enough
but this
this creep reporter on fox news is
promoting it and by the way the clip
goes on
three minutes longer it gets worse and
worse we don't have time to cover the
whole thing on the show this is a
full-throated endorsement
on the news side of fox news of
transgendering the kids
i
i refrain from friendly fire on the
right even among
right-wing personalities and politicians
and organizations that i don't even like
all that much i refrain from friendly
fire generally i try to abide by ronald
reagan's 11th commandment thou shalt not
speak ill of a fellow republican
i cannot think of anything more evil
that fox news could do than endorse
transing kids then encourage parents to
trans their kids and in the other parts
of that segment they say yeah you know
we're using statistics from the trevor
project which is a radical pro lgbt
organization and the statistics say if
you don't trans your little kids they're
going to kill themselves so what you
want do you want to they actually use
this line they say would you rather have
a dead daughter or a living son or
really it's just a girl who's a daughter
who's pretending to be a boy
what do you want you want to kill your
kid well if you don't want to kill your
kid give a ton of money to
pharmaceutical psychos to pump your kid
full of hormones so that you can
permanently screw up their body and
probably give them osteoporosis or
something make them sterile forever when
they come to regret this in 10 years
you're gonna have destroyed their lives
but if you don't do it now you're gonna
kill your kids that's the kind of stuff
that's being promoted on fox news
channel
good grief what has happened
i can't i can't figure it out i
i can't i can't refrain from criticizing
them here i have
i've appeared on fox news about a
bazillion times
i've i've promoted multiple books on fox
news went back last year tucker helped
me promote my book speechless i wish
that the fox news executives had had
read that book i wish they had listened
to some of their own programming this is
insane it's very difficult for me i was
trying to make a joke about what's going
to happen next at fox news
what are they going to promote next
blank you know they're promoting this so
i was trying to think of some hyperbolic
satirical thing i could say what what's
the even crazier thing that they could
promote there's nothing crazier they've
reached it that's the bottom of the
slippery slope
maybe bestiality i'm not i don't think
that's even worse we're talking about
mutilating the genitals of little kids
and if you don't do it you're a terrible
parent they say
this is
it shows you how far america has fallen
it it actually gives some credence to
what nancy pelosi was saying
transvestitism is what america is all
about maybe it is i don't think it's
what ordinary americans are about i
don't think it's what the majority of
the american people are about
but i do think
that it might be what every single one
of our institutions is about including
the quote-unquote conservative ones
including the quote-unquote right-wing
ones there's there's a uniform agreement
now
not just on
the rainbow not just on homosexuality
not just on transgenderism on transing
the freaking little kids
wasn't just
fox news promoting this stuff
you're seeing this now
somehow this is more disgusting it's
probably less
it's less evil but it's definitely more
disgusting there was an ad that came out
from postmates which is a food delivery
service
on
listen i'm no expert in in the nuances
of this particular
sexual ideology but it was
it was the sort of
stuff you should eat
from postmates if you want to engage in
certain activities
what are you eating this pride
well if you're a top it seems like you
can eat whatever you want
but if you're a bottom you're expected
to starve
not this pride introducing the bottom
friendly menu from postmates
we teamed up with dr evan goldstein from
bespoke surgical to bring you a menu of
bottom friendly foods backed by science
insoluble fiber won't help you feel
cubes so avoid things like whole grains
wheat bran cauliflower potatoes legumes
hold up are you just fully diving into
those beans
the problem with these foods is they
don't dissolve in water which could
cause a traffic jam in your digestive
system making a mess of your evening
there's no right or wrong way to bottom
but if you're planning on getting peachy
this pride the bottom friendly menu on
postmates has the kinds of foods that
could keep you feeling good are you
organic
they put the avocado in an s m
leather
studs
metal
that's so gross and i i realized why
they're doing it i couldn't figure out
what this is the most disgusting thing
i've ever seen in any commercial why and
they're doing it because for for years
corporations have been attacked even by
the left-wing lgbt activists they say
you only you just put your logo in a
rainbow for pride you don't really care
you just you it's just you're pandering
but you don't really change anything and
so i know there were there was a board
meeting there was some kind of executive
meeting at postmates and they said you
know we got to really prove it to them
this year we are going to go into the
most absolutely disgusting granular
detail on on lgbt relations and and
we're going to include avocados and
peaches and all sorts of stuff to
digestive tracts and we are we're
committed this year please maybe go back
to the logo i think we were fine with
the logo i'm so glad you like that clip
now ring ding bing bada bada bing bong
subscribe to the michael knowles show
get all of the notifications for every
single video then head on over to
spotify stitch your google play apple
podcast wherever myspace i don't care
wherever subscribe to the michael
knowles show leave a five star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you